wie sehe ich aus
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ich habe mir gedacht ich mache heute mal
ein kleines Make-up Tutorial für euch
und deswegen würde ich sagen wir starten
mal direkt ihr wisst ja ich schminke
mich wirklich nur noch ausschließlich
mit Naturkosmetik mit den ganzen
Annemarie Berlin Sachen und heute gibt's
einfach einen wunderschönen frischen
Look für euch ich habe mich vorhin
einfach kurz frisch gemacht muss mich
jetzt einfach nur noch eincremen ja okay
dann nehmen wir mal die Creme da haben
wir die großen
genau davon nehme ich einfach eine
kleine Menge in die Hand und creme mein
Gesicht damit ein
das tut so
genau ich schließe noch immer gerne
meine Augen damit ich mir die Augen
nicht aussteche aus versehen
Wahnsinn und das ist so ein schöner
erfrischender Effekt ich mache dann
meistens so dass ich mit einem
Augenbrauenstift starte
das heißt ich schminke mir immer zuerst
die Augen genau
liplinine
Carlo Look zu machen
[Musik]
ich gebe es zu manchmal manchmal ist mir
schon nach viel viel Augenbraue da muss
man auch
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ich bürste noch mal
einmal durch dass der Übergang weiche
ist ne das ist dann
genau und jetzt noch links super
hervorragend
zur Seite und jetzt könnt ihr quasi
entscheiden
was Sie als nächstes tun wollt am besten
immerhin Lidschatten ich habe immer zwei
Farben zur Auswahl das ist der Moment
muss ich mal kurz lesen
[Gelächter]
mein Auge ich würde sagen ich nehme
einfach beide
genau der den ich in der Hand habe den
nehme ich einfach so ein bisschen auf
dem beweglichen Augenlid ich mach mal
kurz meine Augen zu
ganz genau einfach so ein bisschen
locker drüber streichen ihr könnt
natürlich auch einen Pinsel verwenden
das bleibt wirklich euch überlassen aber
ihr seht schon schminken geht auch wie
beim Backen und Kochen auch gerne ohne
Werkzeug eure Finger sind das beste
Werkzeug ganz genau am besten setzt sie
auch immer die hellen Farben innen an
ans Innere des Auges und außen einfach
ein bisschen dunkler wer möchte kann
gerne noch den Augenbrauenstift
verwenden und hat sich so am an die
Ecken außen bisschen ansetzen aber heute
denke ich machen wir es lieber nicht
heute reicht es einfach wenn ich ähm die
Betonung auf den Augenbrauen habe dann
geht's weiter mit der Haut genau hier
ist die Formation perfekt einmal kurz
auf dem Handrücken auftragen dürfte
jetzt gerne mit den Händen mit dem
Pinsel oder mit einem Schwämmchen
auftragen am besten immer auf der Nase
anfangen und nach außen zu den Wangen
hin ausstreichen und die sind so leicht
in der Textur trotzdem schön Decken
haben eine ganz tolle Konsistenz riechen
gut man braucht wirklich nur ganz ganz
wenig Produkt das wirklich der Hammer
also so ein Pumper der reicht komplett
aus und ihr seht schon das Hautbild ist
der Wahnsinn Hammer
genau als nächstes
was wir Frauen und Mamas auch gerne
brauchen Concealer natürlich hier vorne
liegt der Concealer in einem leichten
hellenthon hinten einmal drücken muss
man auch tatsächlich gar nicht so viel
Produkt benutzen denn auch der ist total
ergiebig könnt ihr hier auch schön sehen
ne hat eine tolle Farbe tolle Textur und
dann trage ich den einfach mit den
Fingern so ein bisschen unterm Auge auf
macht das ganze Gesicht einfach ein
bisschen frischer am besten einfach
leicht nach oben schauen ein bisschen
höher am Auge genau und leicht nach
außen streichen gerne noch ein bisschen
ein Klopfen
und für den richtig perfekten Beauty
Look am besten noch bisschen auf dem
Nasenrücken das so ein Geheimtipp genau
so ein bisschen Nasenrücken und der
Beste profitipp ist immer über der
Oberlippe so ein leichten Highlighter
setzen
Wahnsinn super ne sieht man gleich oder
und wenn er jetzt später der Lippenstift
drauf kommt
Wahnsinn und dann kommt jetzt mein
Lieblingsprodukt das ist hier der zwei
in 1 Blatt und Bronzer in einem genau
und den trage ich jetzt aber tatsächlich
mit einem Pinsel auf am besten
Entschuldigung und es könnte einfach in
beide Farben einmal rein kurz Lächeln
und dann an den Wangenknochen hier am
Lächeln ansetzen
[Gelächter]
wie frisch das alles aussieht wahnsinn
ich würde sagen ich schließe jetzt
erstmal hier ab mit meinem Rose nature
Spray das fixiert noch mal das Make-up
und schützt aber auch vor blauem Licht
ja also beugt auch der Hautalterung
durch blaues Licht vor genau
Gesicht ganz genau ansonsten würde ich
jetzt hier noch ein Lipliner auswählen
ähm ich nehme jetzt hier den genau nee
das ist ein Pinsel
noch einmal den zweiten ja nein den
nehmen dran den roten genau
zu reden
[Musik]
rechts habe ich noch nicht
rechts oben habe ich noch nichts
tatsächlich an der Oberlippe ich habe es
noch nicht an der Opel
Kontur habt ich finde das ist einfach
ein Lipliner unterm Lippenstift das
gehört sich einfach so habe ich denn
irgendwie meine Lippenstift verlegt
ja ich habe den Lippenstift ich guck mal
ganz kurz für euch welche Farbe
burgundi ja Burger ist eine ganz tolle
Farbe ganz toll passt jetzt heute zum
Look wirklich perfekt
auftragen hat auch eine ganz cremige
Konsistenz
ich habe genug Produkt auf den Lippen
guck mal hier
sehr schön und wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr gerne noch ein bisschen lip-öl
auftragen gibt es auch in zwei Farben
das sieht von außen ein bisschen dunkler
aus als es tatsächlich ist legt eure
Lippen wunderbar macht so einen leichten
Gloss drauf und ist wirklich der Hammer
riecht gut ohne Lippenstift hat
tatsächlich einfach eine leichte Rosé
Farbe es gibt den Lippen so ein bisschen
eine Farbe ohne aber dabei zu dunkel zu
sein das dann so für so Tage wenn ihr
sagt heute will ich jetzt nicht so
man kannte Lippen haben will ist er ein
bisschen leichter aufgetragen haben dann
könnte gerne das Lipödem oder einfach
über den Lippenstift auftragen noch mal
für so einen schönen Glanz oben drauf
kannst natürlich auch essen
[Musik]
so wie ich gerade
perfekt würde ich sagen und das wäre
jetzt mein Look für euch ich hoffe er
gefällt euch und der ein oder andere
macht den nach ich kann da nichts
aussetzen und deshalb würde ich sagen
ich gebe ihr zehn Punkte verdient Punkt
schreibt mir einfach gerne in die
Kommentare wie euch dieses Video
gefallen hat dann mache ich natürlich
gerne ganz ganz viele weitere Make-up
Tutorials für euch hat mir wirklich
super viel Spaß gemacht bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss
[Gelächter]
ich glaube
Lippenstift
ist gar nicht so schlecht ne
[Musik]